Pensemos en Europa como si fuera una
comunidad de vecinos. Tenemos un
Presidente que se encarga de poner orden,
los vecinos que se olvidan de pagar la
comunidad, y hasta el vecino que amenaza
con mudarse si los demás no dejan de
hacer ruidos.
- "Váyase señor Cuesta, váyase"
Pero en general, el buen ambiente y las ideas
comunes son lo que mantienen la comunidad
a flote.
Tanto es así, que algunos vecinos se han
formado sus propias organizaciones,
dentro de la comunidad, para asegurarse
de que todo funciona a la perfección
cómo serían la Unión Europea o la
OSCE, por ejemplo. Pero hay un vecino que
vive ahí y que hace poco ruido, tan poco
que se ha quedado fuera de todos esos
grupos y que además no comparte las
aficiones de los demás de respetar los
derechos humanos de sus ciudadanos o de
darles una democracia transparente. Este
país es Bielorrusia y de ella vamos a
hablar hoy.
Resulta increíble pensar que en pleno
siglo XXI, en Europa, cuna de los derechos
humanos y del buenrollismo internacional,
una dictadura haya conseguido mantenerse
al margen de la fiesta democracia que
comenzó tras la caída del muro de
Berlín. Pero en Bielorrusia, y a pesar de
la celebración periódica de elecciones,
Alexander Lukashenko lleva gobernando lo
mismo que yo llevo viva en esta tierra.
En julio de 1994 y en las que,
probablemente, fueron las últimas
elecciones libres de Bielorrusia, hasta
la fecha,
Lukashenko fue elegido Presidente por un
apabullante 80% de la población.
- " Sin sorpresas en Bielorrusia,
la oposición no ha obtenido ni un solo
escaño en las elecciones legislativas de
ayer".
Una vez elegido, Lukashenko modificó la
Constitución por un referéndum celebrado
dos años después, que incrementaba su
poder como Presidente. En 2004 y tras
haber ganado otras elecciones en 2001, y
también mediante un referéndum,
suprimió la limitación constitucional
de un máximo de dos mandatos
presidenciales consecutivos, lo que le
daba vía libre para justificar su
presencia en el gobierno hasta el
infinito.
Veintidós años y tres procesos electorales
después, Lukashenko sigue a la cabeza de
Bielorrusia, y lo que es más interesante,
su popularidad no parece disminuir a
pesar de la crisis económica que
atraviesa uno de los países más pobres
de Europa. Una crisis tan grande que, para
que os hagáis una idea, Bielorrusia
ha tenido que redenominar el rublo
bielorruso el pasado julio, quitándole
hasta cuatro ceros a la derecha.
Entonces ¿qué es lo que hace que un
líder tan poco carismático consiga
perdurar tantísimo en el tiempo?
Bien es sabido que, Lukashenko, viene de
una familia modesta, y que antes de ser
Presidente de Bielorrusia fue
Vicepresidente de una granja colectiva
estatal. Es éste pasado humilde lo que
hace que los bielorruso se sientan
identificados con él y confían en que
sabrá defender sus intereses.
Además, la permanencia durante dos
décadas de la misma persona al mando de
Bielorrusia ha generado entre los
ciudadanos una idea de estabilidad que un
gobierno democrático no podría darles,
especialmente en el contexto que está
atravesando ahora mismo su vecina
Ucrania.
Eso y que desde hace unos años la tasa
de desempleo se encuentra en torno a un
1% por el control casi total del
gobierno sobre la economía.
Por eso, a pesar de la recesión que
atraviesa el país, Lukashenko es y
seguirá siendo la mejor opción a ojos
de los bielorusos, aunque desde el punto
de vista occidental sea de todo menos un
líder deseable.
También sabemos que Lukashenko no se anda con
chiquitas, y que, igual que cualquier otro
dictador, basa su permanencia en el poder
muchas veces en el uso de la fuerza.
- "Las elecciones presidenciales en Bielorrusia
se saldaron con manifestaciones de la
oposición y las detenciones de cientos
de personas, incluidos varios candidatos
a la presidencia".
En el caso de Bielorrusia, esto viene reforzado por:
1. la permanencia de la KGB, que ahora
mismo se disfraza del Comité para la
Seguridad Estatal de Bielorrusia".
2. El hecho de que la pena de muerte aún
sea legal en el país.
- "Las confesiones de los jóvenes se habrían obtenido a la
fuerza,
aún así ambos son condenados a morir
de un tiro en la nuca".
Bielorrusia es el único país
europeo que mantiene vigente la pena de
muerte en su ordenamiento jurídico,
las autoridades bielorrusas justifican
su mantenimiento en el gran apoyo que
goza entre la población.
El 80% de los bielorusos se postulan a
favor de la medida. Pero, aparte del apoyo
popular,
esta medida es de gran ayuda para el
hermético régimen de Lukashenko ya que
gracias a ella
poca gente se atreve a hacerle cara a
"batka" o papá, como se le conoce en
Bielorrusia.
Curiosamente, más que por crímenes
contra individuos, la pena capital se
suele aplicar por crímenes contra el
estado, lo que en una dictadura se
traduce simplemente por oposición al
régimen.
- "La unión europea exige la puesta en
libertad de todos los opositores
detenidos y encarcelados desde diciembre
de 2010 cuando la oposición salió a
las calles para denunciar el fraude en
las elecciones presidenciales".
No se sabe exactamente a cuánta gente ha castigado
bielorrusia de esta manera pero sí se
sabe que, en 2016, ha tenido lugar la
primera ejecución después de tres
años de una pausa que comenzó por las
sanciones impuestas por la Unión
Europea tras la extraña desaparición
de dos miembros de la oposición. Las
sanciones, que prohibían a Lukashenko, y a
otras 170 personas, viajar a Europa,
además de sanciones económicas, han
sido retiradas por la supuesta mejora de
la situación de los derechos humanos en
el país. Algo ilógico pero que podría
explicarse con el siguiente punto de la
estrategia política de Lukashenko.
Lukashenko sabe
perfectamente que la economía que
dirige no tiene nada que hacer sin sus
vecinos.
Bielorrusia es un país sin salida al
mar, que depende totalmente del comercio,
o bien con Rusia o con la Unión Europea.
Así que, si tiene que dejar de lado
temporalmente a Putin por pactar con
Europa, o viceversa, no tiene
inconveniente en hacerlo.
La última prueba de ello: la entrada en
el parlamento, en 2016, de las primeras
opositoras desde la llegada de
Lukashenko para tratar de acercarse a occidente
- "Tras 20 años de ausencia, la
oposición bielorrusa ha logrado un
escaño en el parlamento".
Otra jugada magistral del país fue
alzarse como mediador entre ambas partes
durante el conflicto de Ucrania en 2014
y 2015 con los acuerdos de Minsk, que
deberían haber puesto fin al conflicto.
Lo que le valió el beneplácito de la
Unión Europea. Aunque, ojo, que hay que
recordar que Bielorrusia es un país
miembro tanto de la Comunidad de Estados
Independientes como de la Organización
del Tratado para la Seguridad Colectiva,
que viene a ser el nuevo Pacto de
Varsovia orquestado por Rusia. Por lo
que por mucho que se acerque a Europa,
Bielorrusia siempre le deberá una
cierta lealtad a Rusia. Aunque cabe
destacar que los primeros que adoran a
Rusia son los propios ciudadanos. Cuando
se les pregunta ¿con quién se siente
más relacionado, Rusia o Europa?
Tres cuartas partes de los bielorrusos
responden Rusia, algo que no pasa, por
ejemplo, en las zonas libres de Ucrania o
en los bálticos.
Cabe destacar que, al igual que sus
vecinos del norte y tras la guerra de
Ucrania, los bielorrusos se están
preguntando ahora si ellos serán los
siguientes en ser visitados por las
fuerzas armadas rusas. A priori, no parece
que vaya a ser el caso, ya que los
gobiernos de ambas partes tienen una muy
buena relación, y Bielorrusia ya aloja
algunas bases militares rusas a las que
el Kremlin puede acceder sin necesidad
de usar la fuerza. Pero no os asustéis que,
a pesar de todo, Bielorrusia es un país
totalmente visitable y os puedo asegurar
que Minsk es una ciudad preciosa y
totalmente segura.
Así que si os atrevéis y os sacáis la Visa,
poder visitarla y si eso, dejarnos
vuestras experiencias en los comentarios.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.
¡Y suscribiros al canal, qué mola mucho!